[Music]
so I think inaccurate portraits of
animals can lead to ineffective
conservation plans so for example take
the panda so here is an animal that is
hugely adored and hugely
anthropomorphised pandas kind of a
basically cute crack they trigger our
reward center into releasing chemicals
that make us want to nurture because the
Panda looks a little bit like a toddler
stumbling around so it fires off this
instinct in us so we are kind of
helpless not to love it and we have
infantilized pandas we think that they
are completely helpless and they can't
survive without our intervention and
this is I think complete rubbish there
are two pandas you see there is the wild
panda which is a secret stud with a
taste for flesh and and beautifully
evolved to survive in its unique
environment then there is a captive
panda now the captive panda we all are
very familiar where there's a creature
which doesn't really like to reproduce
and it's it's a pretty helpless creature
but that's that's because animals in
captivity it's incredibly hard to get
animals in captivity to breed you know
animals have a wide range of
environmental and behavioral cues that
are necessary in order to get them in
the mood it's the animal equivalent of a
glass of wine and a bit of Barry White
and and if you don't get that right if
you don't know what that is then it's
going to be very hard to get them to
reproduce in captivity in the case of
pandas pandas actually occupy a
surprisingly large range and although
they are quite solitary as creatures
they advertise their availability as it
were on these trees that act as kind of
noticeboards they're a bit like Panda
ten
if you like the female when she comes
into East hrus which is as we know a
very narrow window she will she will rub
herself and her scent against one of
these message boards trees and then that
will draw males in to also leave their
message to sort of say hey what about me
and leave their advert now there their
advert that they leave is a is a scented
advert it's included in their their
urine so the females like males that can
squirt their urine the highest up the
tree so males engage in what can only be
described as a sort of urinary Olympics
in order to squirt their pee as high up
the tree as possible and the scientific
paper that expose this is got this sort
of fantastic terminology in it that
there are a plethora of positions that
the pander adopts from
squat to leg kick to even handstand in
order to get their pee highest up the
tree and then the female will then
choose which male she wants now it's a
very different situation from being in a
zoo where two pandas are clumped
together in a in a in a concrete
environment and expected to reproduce
and of course that fails so we then have
this opinion in it becomes very popular
we love to read about how useless pandas
are at sex I think it makes us feel
better about ourselves quite frankly and
so yeah I think I think it helps us feel
superior actually and so you know those
those stories are incredibly popular and
so we we have this idea that there's
this this bear that is somehow hopeless
and this evolutionary mishap that unless
we micromanage its life isn't going to
survive when actual fact in the wild the
Panda is doing just fine they are you
know they they find mates and when they
do find mates they will they've been
observed having sex up to 40 times in a
single afternoon so you know the pack
the female pandas narrow window
fertility which is always ridiculed as
being this sort of you know problem by
actually
just be a means of of controlling the
population size because the male panda
is in fact so virile that panda sperm is
10 to 100 times more dense than human
sperm only they're feral creatures
they're not hopeless evolutionary losers
so so the problem with a lot of Chinese
panda conservation is that it revolves
around captive breeding and the Chinese
have become extremely good at breeding
pandas in captivity and not not
necessarily because they've worked out
how to get pandas in the mood the
they've worked out what that Panda
equivalent of of Barry White is but it's
actually because they're using
artificial insemination and a loss of
cases which is is an otter is a pretty
eye watering way of reproducing and but
it's extremely effective I visited some
of these panda breeding centers in China
I went about ten years ago and I was
astonished when I visited because they
were these sort of brutalist concrete
buildings
it didn't seem anything like the
mountainous bamboo forests where the
pandas were from and yet they were
producing these bumper crops of baby
pandas now the reason why they're so
successful is because they're using
artificial insemination and a lot of the
pandas give birth to twins and they keep
both twins alive and they switch out
they will they'll keep switching the
pandas the the twins around so that both
twins stay alive but neither really gets
to stay with its mother and then the
pandas are then these baby pandas you'll
see them there's always always these
ridiculous photos that go completely
viral of you know men dressed in blue
holding you know masses of pandas or
baby pandas all playing together on
slides or whatever but this is a totally
unnatural situation in the wild
female panda she might give birth to
twins but probably only one of them is
going to survive and then her and her
cub will spend you know a year or more
together in the wild while the cub
watches and learns how to be a wild
panda from its mother here you have in
captivity completely different situation
you have all these baby pandas being
reared together in a crash and there are
no wild pandas there teaching them how
to be wild pandas and of course this is
the problem is that you know animals
might physically be there but it's the
behavior that makes an animal as well
and and the behavior has to be some
behavior is innate of course but a large
amount of behavior is learned and so you
know these these pandas that are bred in
these but effectively panda mills they
look like pandas but they aren't really
pandas because they don't know how to
behave like pandas so when they're
released into the wild they don't know
how to behave they you know these are
the although they're fairly solitary
they're still social enough that you
know pandas need to know how to you know
attract a mate how to to deal with with
an arrival male who's territory you
stepped on if they Davin learnt how to
behave in that way then they're never
going to survive and in fact the first
captive raised panda that was released
by the Chinese it was unfortunately
called lucky but it was anything but
because it ended up being savaged to
death by wild pandas so it's difficult
because these captive bred populations
are now a long line of animals that have
been bred in captivity their wildness is
sort of disappearing you know and with
this in mind the Chinese government have
experimented more recently with trying
to sort of raise some pandas
away further away from human contact and
so they've got humans dressed in panda
costumes pushing around leopards stuff
leopards on wheels as a way of sort of
teaching them about predators and you
know I've seen that that was in a big
spread in National Geographic in fact
you know it makes a fantastic photo
story it's a funny thing isn't it people
dressed as pandas teaching pandas has to
be pandas but it's complete nonsense of
course they can't you know so I feel
like these things are these stories are
like hugely popular bumper crops of baby
pandas people dressed as pandas teaching
pandas has to be pandas we're saving
them we're sorting this problem
look science has got the answer it's all
okay you're all all right at home don't
worry about it carry on doing what
you're doing it's all getting sorted but
it isn't it isn't getting sorted and
that is not the answer the answer is
just the opposite leave them alone
leave them alone in their territory and
let them get on with doing what they
need to do let them get on with living
their lives and surviving like they have
done for many millennia
[Music]
you